[Música]
sectores oficialistas de Bolivia
bloquearon la región de Santa Cruz como
respuesta a la huelga que desde hace
días exige un nuevo censo de población
para pedir más presupuesto el gobierno
ordenó la suspensión temporal de la
exportación de los principales productos
de la región para contrarrestar la
escasez tenemos información desde La Paz
la economía estadounidense creció en un
2,6% en el último trimestre todo ello en
medio de un panorama de alta inflación y
aumento de las tasas de interés que
preocupan a muchas familias antes de las
elecciones de medio término del 8 de
noviembre tenemos análisis sobre la
situación
en francés 24 seguimos cubriendo la
campaña para la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales de Brasil que
tendrá lugar este domingo en esta
ocasión les traemos un informe sobre el
aumento del porte de armas durante el
gobierno de Jair bolsonaro
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Soy
Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos esta emisión en
la región de Santa Cruz en Bolivia motor
económico del país que vivió una nueva
jornada de huelga contra el gobierno de
Luis Arce en busca de un nuevo censo
poblacional que permita destinarles más
presupuesto sectores oficialistas
bloquearon la región como respuesta
Mientras que el gobierno ordenó la
suspensión temporal de la exportación de
los principales productos de la región
por temoraldesa abastecimiento nuestra
corresponsal en La Paz merivaca nos
ampliaba previamente la información
Santa Cruz la región más próspera de
Bolivia cumple su sexto día de paro
indefinido exigiendo al gobierno de Luis
Arce la realización del censo de
población y vivienda el año 2023 y no el
2024 como pretende el poder ejecutivo
los dirigentes de Santa Cruz pretenden
que antes de las elecciones de 2025 con
base en estos resultados del censo se
realiza un nuevo reparto de recursos
pues la ciudad de Santa Cruz ha sido
receptora de migración en los últimos
años y por otro lado también buscan que
se haga una redistribución de escaños
parlamentarios pues consideran que les
corresponden más por tener más población
la medida de presión se realiza en medio
de alta tensión Pues los sectores que
apoyan al gobierno de Luis Arce han
instalado un bloqueo en las carreteras
en torno a la ciudad de Santa Cruz para
impedir el ingreso o la salida de
alimentos o de cualquier otro producto
es una especie de cerco que según los
dirigentes de Santa Cruz pretende
asfixiar y castigar a la ciudadanía en
paralelo el gobierno ha decretado la
suspensión de las exportaciones de
productos de Santa Cruz entre ellos el
azúcar la carne la soya y sus derivados
lo que ha sido rechazado por el sector
empresarial pues considera que esta
medida perjudica todo el país y no
solamente a unos cuantos empresarios de
Santa Cruz el conflicto también ha
escalado a otras regiones por ejemplo se
han registrado enfrentamientos en las
últimas horas en los departamentos de la
paz y tarija exigiendo también la
realización del censo de población y
vivienda para el año 2023 de acuerdo a
un informe de la oficina de las Naciones
Unidas para la coordinación de asuntos
humanitarios cerca de 95.000 personas en
Colombia han vivido confinadas debido a
la violencia en los primeros nueve meses
del 2022 se trata de la cifra más alta
en los últimos 10 años en ese país que
tienen marcha un acuerdo de paz con uno
de los actores armados y desde el
gobierno del presidente Gustavo Petro
impulsan la llamada Paz total
cifra recorde en Colombia
95.000 personas han vivido confinadas en
los primeros nueve meses de 2022 es el
número más alto en 10 años pero no es un
confinamiento de pandemia sino por el
conflicto armado personas que no pueden
salir de sus casas ni comunidades
al lado otra cifra de impacto
74.000 personas han sido Víctimas de
desplazamiento masivo es decir por la
violencia han tenido que dejar sus
comunidades es el último informe de la
oficina de la ONU para la coordinación
de asuntos humanitarios que pese a todo
reconocen que en el mes de septiembre ha
descendido la violencia en medio de las
intenciones del gobierno de Gustavo
Petro de lograr la que ha llamado Paz
total el equipo humanitario en Colombia
formado por más de un centenar de
agencias también dijo que el 15% de la
población necesita asistencia
humanitaria Mientras que el país vive
una infrafinanciación para afrontar
causas estructurales pese a todo este
jueves el consejo de seguridad de las
Naciones Unidas renovó la misión
humanitaria Un año más la adopción
unánime de esta resolución hoy demuestra
el compromiso continuo del Consejo de
Seguridad con la paz en Colombia y con
la implementación integral del acuerdo
de paz Mientras tanto el canciller de
Colombia Álvaro Leyva dijo en una cumbre
de cancilleres europeos y
latinoamericanos que España y chile
serán acompañantes del nuevo proceso de
paz en Colombia
seguimos ahora en Estados Unidos allí
este jueves se anunció que la economía
creció en un 2,6% en el último trimestre
unas cifras que mejoran las expectativas
y rompen la tendencia a la baja de los
dos trimestres anteriores todo ello en
medio de un panorama de alta inflación y
aumento de las tasas de interés y poco
antes de las elecciones de medio término
del 8 de noviembre en las que la
economía se ha mostrado como tema clave
anteriormente pudimos hablar con el
analista Alberto Bernal León al respecto
definitivamente la inflación afecta Pues
eso lo sentimos todas las personas que
vivimos en Estados Unidos y que la el
dinero alcanza para menos Bueno la
verdad esto esto Esto es cierto que son
fenómeno mundial en todas partes está
pasando lo mismo Entonces eso afecta por
un lado también la caída de los precios
de las acciones como en Estados Unidos
casi todas las familias tienen algo que
ver con el con el Mercado o sea con el
dow Jones con el nasdaq etcétera porque
la gente tiene sus cuentas de retiro y
invertidas en estos activos entonces en
el subconsciente cuando caen los precios
de las acciones la gente tiende a
ponerse un poco más parca con su gasto
entonces por eso gasta menos y es
obviamente afecta Y por último es algo
que se ha estado es muy claro es que con
la con el mayor con el incremento tan
fuerte que se ha visto en las tasas de
interés Pues la verdad es que comprar
una casa para una familia por medio en
Estados Unidos hoy en día está muy
difícil porque se ha subido la cuota de
la hipoteca en una forma brutal
Además del doble Entonces todo esto va a
comenzar a afectar y yo creo que es una
de las razones por las cuales es bien
probable el partido republicano gane las
elecciones en el congreso que recupere
la cámara y que recupere el senado
también y el próximo domingo Brasil
Elige a su presidente entre Yair
bolsonaro y Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
durante el mandato de bolsonaro el
número de armas en manos de
coleccionistas y tiradores deportivos se
triplicó en las elecciones legislativas
del pasado 2 de octubre este grupo
consiguió un número récord de
representantes En total son 16 diputados
federales y siete senadores que
integrarán el grupo parlamentario de La
bala con el fin de flexibilizar el porte
de armas para la población civil
hace ocho años rildo Angels fundó este
club de tiro en niteroy cerca de Río de
Janeiro
su pasión por las pistolas y los fusiles
viene de años atrás
para este militar reservista el acceso a
un arma es un derecho inalienable de la
población que el presidente bolsonaro
intentó asegurar a golpe de decreto
sin embargo la Corte Suprema del
Congreso tumbaron todas las leyes que
amplían el porte de armas el camino
encontrado fue triplicar el arsenal de
coleccionistas y tiradores deportivos
el nivel ideal que queremos alcanzar no
se refiere a la cantidad de armas de
fuego es una cuestión de democracia si
no quieres tener armas está bien pero no
luches contra mi derecho de querer tener
una lo ideal es que toda la población se
acostumbre a este derecho que es la
libertad y luego cada uno escoja lo que
hace
rildo saluda con entusiasmo la elección
de 23 nuevos parlamentarios que
integrarán el lobby de La bala en el
congreso este militar niega que los
tiradores deportivos preparen una
insurrección Armada en caso de derrota
de bolsonaro
está más que probado que con toda esta
Liberación entre comillas que tuvimos si
hubiésemos querido hacer algo ya lo
hubiéramos hecho desde hace mucho tiempo
nuestros derechos han sido totalmente
cercados al tumbar los decretos del
presidente y nos mantuvimos siempre en
La Paz más absoluta
Brasil tiene una gran tradición
armamentista la primera medalla olímpica
en 1920 fue en la modalidad de tiro
deportivo
algunos investigadores alertan sobre el
riesgo de que está proliferación de
armas asociada a una flexibilización de
los controles a cabe beneficiando el
crimen
ya tenemos un impacto en diferentes
formas de violencia violencia contra la
mujer y fortalecimiento de la actuación
del crimen organizado es importante
también recordar que la defensa del
armamento de la población hace que se
mande un mensaje errado de que la
violencia es una forma legítima de
resolución de conflictos en una
democracia
en su opinión el avance del lobby de las
armas representa un retroceso en el
estatuto del desarme que desde 2003
intenta reducir la circulación de armas
y establece pena más duras para crímenes
como el porta ilegal o el contrabando
hasta aquí este informativo sigan con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]